[Applaus]
der präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren zumindest in einem punkt hat
diese koalition geschafft was vorher
noch keiner bundesregierung gelungen ist
obwohl sie gerade mal oder weniger als
ein jahr im amt ist gibt es mit ausnahme
der beteiligten personen wahrscheinlich
niemanden in diesem land denn nicht auf
ihr baldiges ende hofft die bevölkerung
hat die koalition satt weil sie mit
ihren schlechten kompromissen und
gegenseitige blockaden erkennt man nicht
in der lage ist die wirklichen probleme
der menschen zu lösen ja und die
konzernlenker und finanz mario sie die
hoffen natürlich längst dass mit
friedrich merz bald einer der ihren ins
kanzleramt einzieht der dann ihre
wünsche weit bedingungsloser und
rücksichtslose erfüllt als das aktuelle
kabinett
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
genau diese art genau diese art von
politik können wir uns immer weniger
leisten
schauen wir uns doch die
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
der einbruch der deutschen wirtschaft im
dritten quartal zeigt an dass es mit der
konjunktur bald nicht mehr so laufen
könnte wie in den letzten jahren auch
weil die ständigen deutschen
exportüberschüsse gegenreaktionen
geradezu provozieren um den binnenmarkt
zu stärken brauchen wir aber dringend
höhere löhne bessere renten und wir
brauchen eine regierung die in sachen
öffentlicher investitionen endlich ihre
aufgaben erfüllt und das tun sie nicht
auch wenn sie hier immer so tun als wäre
das so und auch können
auch auf den finanzmärkten ziehen längst
wieder dunkle wolken auf die diskrepanz
zwischen verschuldung und
wirtschaftsleistung ist global weit
größer als vor der letzten großen krise
und trotzdem haben sie es bis heute
versäumt die spekulation einzudämmen und
die banken zu zwingen die ersparnisse
der bürgerinnen und bürger abzusichern
aber wir brauchen dringend eine
regierung die das nachholt und nicht
einen finanzminister der jetzt auch noch
die finanztransaktionssteuer kalt
beerdigt weil er alle derivate kunst
konnte alle derivategeschäfte komplett
ausklammern will was ist das für ein
kotau vor der finanzmafia die
digitalisierung die digitalisierung ist
inzwischen ein modethema wir haben sie
heute auch wieder hier gehört aber am
eigentlichen problem wird zuverlässig
vorbeigeredet und das problem ist dass
der mensch eben nicht im mittelpunkt
stehen kann
solange diese schlüsseltechnologie des
21 jahrhunderts fünf monopolisten aus
dem silicon valley überlassen wird die
längst einen globalen überwachungs
kapitalismus aufgebaut haben wo sogar
case schlimmste befürchtungen in den
schatten gestellt wird
und deswegen brauchen wir brauchen eine
regierung die diese enteignung der
privatsphäre endlich gesetzlich stoppt
und wir brauchen digitale plattformen in
gemeinnützigen eigentum wettbewerb eben
in diesem bereich nicht funktioniert
wegen netzwerkeffekte auf klimawandel
bauen unseren ressourcen all das bedroht
unsere zukunft aber wer dem einhalt
gebieten will der muss schleunigst
aussteigen aus einer wegwerf wirtschaft
in der marktbeherrschende konzerne es
sich leisten können produkte extra so zu
konstruieren dass sie schnell kaputt
gehen und dass sie sich möglichst nicht
reparieren lassen und deswegen brauchen
wir eine politik die innovative
technologien die kreative firmen fördert
statt subventionen an die best vernetzen
großunternehmen zu verteilen
keine bundesregierung
eine bundesregierung die in brüssel
strengere abgasnormen verhindert und
deren regierungspartei cdu sich das von
den bmw eigentümern quandt mit einer
großspende von 700.000 euro bezahlen
lässt eine solche regierung ist nicht
nur ein klimapolitischer blindgänger
sondern steht auch für genau die art
geschmierter politik die viele menschen
an der demokratie verzweifeln lässt
auch die geopolitischen gefahren wachsen
dass donald trump nach dem iran nach
kommt jetzt auch noch den vertrag
kündigen will und damit eine neue welle
atomare aufrüstung auslösen könnte das
ist eine ernste gefahr für den
weltfrieden und es ist vor allem eine
gefahr für die sicherheit hier in europa
und diese zumutungen die müssen doch
endlich durch eine selbstbewusste
europäische friedenspolitik beantwortet
werden aber dafür brauchen wir eine
bundesregierung die den mut hat die
entspannungs politik willy brandts
wiederzubeleben und nicht eine nicht
eine wie sie den mob phones klar
aber eine europäische interventionsarmee
1 klingt bei denen es nicht zuletzt
darum geht den parlamentsvorbehalt für
neue kriegseinsätze auszuhebeln und frau
merkel sie haben ja vor in sehr
engagiert über migration gesprochen und
sie haben über die vielen kriege auf
dieser welt gesprochen
ja wo kommen denn diese kriege her wer
munitioniert denn diese kriege das sind
doch nicht zuletzt deutschland mit dem
waffenexporten oder waren die auslöser
oft genug auf rohstoff kriege letzten
westlicher staaten die aus bünde um
dieser länder
das sind doch die ursachen tun wir doch
nicht so als eine flucht und migration
etwas wofür es keine politische
verantwortlichkeit gibt dafür gibt es
politische verantwortlichkeiten und
deswegen ist es ursache und die muss man
endlich beseitigen
da würde ich von ihm hier mal
konsequenzen den schuh ich finde wir
haben uns viel zu sehr an die
unfähigkeit von regierungen gewöhnt wie
kann es sein dass es in einem reichen
land nicht zu schaffen ist oder
angeblich nicht zu schaffen ist brücken
und straßen in einem ordentlichen
zustand zu erhalten und dafür sorge zu
tragen dass auch ländliche regionen
zugang zu schnell im internet und gut im
funknetz haben und das was hier gerade
wieder gesagt wird das haben wir doch
vor drei vier fünf jahren alles auch
schon gehört und trotzdem ist es nicht
besser geworden
und wie kann es sein dass sie nicht in
der lage sind alte menschen vor armut zu
schützen oder allen kindern eine gute
bildung zu ermöglichen aber ausgereicht
für die beschaffung von waffen und
kriegsgerät schon wieder 4,7 milliarden
euro oben drauf legen drauf auf einen
rüstungsetat der schon in den letzten
jahren unverantwortlich schnell
gewachsen ist christopher der politik
meinte position wirklich meinen sie
wirklich dass zufriedene
rüstungslobbyisten wichtiger sind als
zufriedene wähler wenn sie das meinen
dann muss ich sagen ist es wirklich kein
wunder dass es mit solchen parteien
bergab geht
und dann gebe ich ja zu ich gebe ja zur
schmerzt uns nicht allzu sehr wenn die
union wähler verliert aber was uns
wirklich ein rätsel ist ist die
strategie der spd-mann es ist keine zwei
wochen her da haben sie auf ihrem
debatten camp absolut vernünftige
forderungen formuliert gegen hartz iv
für eine erneuerung des sozialstaats für
eine rentenversicherung in die alle
einzahlen das finden wir gut weil wir
wären heilfroh wenn wir in zukunft für
solche dinge nicht mehr alleine kämpfen
müssen
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der spd
wenn sie das alles auch nur etwas ernst
meinen wie können sie dann diese
rüstungs haushalt diesem ausrüstungs
haushalt zu schwimmen
lang ein bisschen gerechter machen wird
wenn wir solche ihnen denn noch
irgendetwas glauben wenn sie
gleichzeitig an der koalition mit der
union festhalten mit der sie garantiert
keine einzige dieser forderungen
umsetzen können
sie machen doch ihre glaubwürdigkeit
immer mehr kaputt sie können die besten
dinge formulieren das nimmt ihnen keiner
mehr ab und ich finde das traurig das
möchte ich schon deutlich sehr
internationalen unsere nationalhymne die
sie ja alle gern sehen beschwert
einigkeit und recht und freiheit
aber wir leben nicht in einem einigen
land sondern in einem das sozial und
zunehmend auch kulturell tief gespalten
ist
es gibt diejenigen die vom aktuellen
wirtschafts boom profitieren und es gibt
andere an denen das wachstum seit jahren
komplett vorbei geht und es gibt
offensichtlich auch zwei recht in
unserem land einst für die normalen
bürger und eins für die oberen
zehntausend die konzernlenker wo
gemeingefährliche betrügereien mit den
dieselabgasen komplett ohne konsequenzen
bleiben
nein die werden dann lieber auf die
dieselfahrer abgewälzt denen inzwischen
sogar auf einer autobahn fahrverbot
drohen und diese regierung schaut zu und
erklärt sich für nicht zuständig wie
blamabel ist das denn
oder wenden
wenn können eine gangster mit wenigen
finanzgeschäften die steuerzahler
ausplündern
da stehen die finanzminister jahrelang
schmiede
stellen sie sich mal vor ein
kleinunternehmer hätte das gemacht was
mit comics generalstabsmäßig abgelaufen
ist
rechnungen für dinge bei der steuer
einreichen die er gar nicht besitzt
sondern sich nur kurzfristig ausgeliehen
hat und diese rechnung dann auch noch
fleißig kopieren und alle seine kumpel
animieren dass sie die auch noch
einreichen und sich steuern erstatten
lassen die sie nicht gezahlt haben ich
wette mit ihnen
der mann setzte binnen wochen spätestens
binnen wohner wenigen monaten im
gefängnis
die comics betrüger dagegen die haben
uns über viele viele jahre haben sie den
steuerzahler um milliarden geprellt
allein in deutschland um 32 milliarden
aber keiner von ihnen wurde bisher in
handschellen abgeführt und noch nicht
mal hat man ihnen das geld wieder
abgenommen was ist denn das für eine
politik und dann wundern sie sich dass
die menschen nicht nur an der demokratie
sondern auch ein rechtsstaat zeichen
wir haben die freiheit wie frei ist denn
eine gesellschaft in der die meisten die
in arme verhältnisse hineingeboren
wurden diese armut lebenslang nicht mehr
entkommen
die hans-böckler-stiftung hat es doch
gerade noch einmal belegt wer in
deutschland einmal unten ist der bleibt
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit unten
und wer gegen reich geboren ist der hat
beste chancen sein leben im luxus zu
genießen ohne dass sie irgendetwas
relevant ist dafür leisten muss ich
finde das sind solche ideale
verhältnisse und das hat mit den
ansprüchen einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft nichts zu tun
wir haben
frau bundeskanzlerin in der ersten
regierungserklärung in dieser legislatur
viel vom sozialen zusammenhalt
gesprochen
aber genau diesen zusammenhalt den hat
doch die politik der letzten jahre
zerstört
deutschland hat sich verändert und zwar
in eine richtung die vielen menschen
angst macht das klima ist rauer kälter
und aggressiver geworden und das ist
letztlich das spiegelbild der kälte und
rücksichtslosigkeit die sich in unserer
gesellschaft und vor allem in der
arbeitswelt ausgebreitet haben es ist
doch bekannt wie heute bei ryanair bei
amazon bei der deutschen post seinen
vielen anderen unternehmen mit
mitarbeitern umgesprungen wird und es
sind ihre gesetze die das möglich machen
die möglich machen dass menschen in
schlecht bezahlten jobs gedemütigt
werden oder dass sie als leiharbeiter
und dauer befristete der wirkung ihrer
arbeitgeber in besonderem maße
ausgeliefert sind die möglich machen
dass arbeitslose im jobcenter
schikaniert werden als würden sie um
almosen betteln und dabei handelt es
sich oft um menschen die jahrelang
geschuftet und in die sozialversicherung
eingezahlt haben und wenn sie wissen
wollen
wenn sie wissen wollen wie das leben für
viele menschen jenseits der
kernsanierten wohlfühl zonen aussieht
dann lesen sie die vielen tausend
einträge unter dem kürzlich gestarteten
hashtag unten
da geht es um abstieg um ausgrenzung und
demütigungen und um zukunftsangst auch
der fdp würde es mal gut tun da rein zu
gucken
auch das
auch das ist deutschland aber diesem
deutschland geht es nicht gut
und dieses deutschland muss sich
schlicht verhöhnt fühlen wenn es ihre
schönen wetter reden hört und ich finde
wir brauchen eine regierung die sich
diesen menschen wieder zuwendet die den
sozialstaat erneuert und damit
sicherheit und planbarkeit in ihr leben
zurück bringen und ich fand es schon
bedauerlich frau merkel das heute in
ihrer gesamten erklärung die soziale
frage und die situation die lebens
ängste der menschen in diesem land
überhaupt keine rolle gespielt haben so
können wir doch nicht weitermachen
wir brauchen keine weitere senkung des
arbeitslosen bei etwa wir brauchen eine
wiederherstellung einer soliden
arbeitslosen versicherung und wer
mittlere und untere einkommen entlasten
will der kann noch im weg österreichs
gehen der zahl der arbeitgeber zur
rentenversicherung mehr als zwei
prozentpunkte mehr als die arbeitnehmer
und wenn dann noch eine einzelne die
rentenkasse auch selbständige und beamte
dann müsste niemand mehr angst vor
altersarmut haben oder oder schauen sie
sich den wohnungsmarkt an es gab mal
eine zeit da wurde die bereitstellung
von wohnraum in unserem landkreis
öffentliche aufgabe begriffen
dann wurde ein großteil der wohnungen an
private immobilienfonds verscherbelt und
das ergebnis ist offensichtlich anstelle
eines grundrechts sind wohnungen heute
ein beliebtes spekulationsobjekt gewesen
geworden und er mietwucher führt nicht
nur zu wachsender armut er führt auch
dazu dass ärmere und wohlhabende
menschen immer seltener in dem gleichen
viertel wohnen und auch das zerstört den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
da haben sie
warum sie zu beginn dieser koalition
pompös ein heimat ministerium geschaffen
aber ich frage sie was ist denn die
wichtigste basis dafür dass menschen
eine heimat haben wo sie sich wohlfühlen
können das ist doch ein sicheres zuhause
wo sie wohnen können ohne angst zu haben
von der nächsten meet verhöhnung
verdrängt zu werden als er sich frau
merkel darum können sich reicht man sich
kümmern wenn sie ernsthaft heimat etwas
in die saison gehen und eine vernünftige
wohnungspolitik die würde noch nicht mal
die öffentliche hand so viel mehr geld
kosten
17 milliarden werden heute bundesweit
dafür ausgegeben mit wohngeld und
wohnkosten zuschüssen den menschen die
explodierenden mieten etwas erträglicher
zu machen und statt so mit öffentlichem
geld am ende die taschen der mieter zu
füllen wäre es doch weit sinnvoller
einen sofortigen mietpreis stopp
durchzusetzen und die eingesparten
milliarden für ein neues bonusprogramm
in öffentlichen
der rückkauf kommunale wohnen
einzusetzen aber dass sie dass sie
solide wirtschaften können und sparsam
mit dem geld der steuerzahler umgehen
das gehört ja sowieso zu den großen fake
news ihrer politik die wahrheit ist sie
spalten nicht nur unser land sie sind
auch noch besonders teuer mit ihrer
politik da fördern sie überall bei
bauvorhaben autobahn oder
schulsanierungen sogenannte öffentlich
private partnerschaften wobei die
partnerschaft regelmäßig darin besteht
dass die öffentliche hand gemolken wird
und die privaten investoren
risikofreudiger renditen absahnen und je
deshalb sind solche projekte immer
teurer als wenn der staat selbst
investiert und trotzdem fördern sie das
mit ungebrochener begeisterung in vielen
verwaltungen fehlt qualifiziertes
personal
es fehlen polizisten auf den straßen des
fehlen erzieher lehrer sozialarbeiter
pflegekräfte und dabei wäre schon
einiges gewonnen wenn das geld was etwa
für die pflege bereitsteht vollständig
dafür eingesetzt werden könnte
qualifiziertes personal und anständige
gehälter zu bezahlen statt wie das heute
der fall ist auch noch die lukrativen
gewinne der finanzinvestoren
mitzufinanzieren die immer mehr
pflegeheime übernehmen
krankenhäuser sind keineswegs sind
und wir sind überzeugt hilflose alte
menschen und deren pflegende hungrigen
hedgefonds zu überlassen das ist einfach
nur schäbig und der ministerien das
gleiche ele stadt auf eigene beamte zu
vertrauen und die entsprechend zu
qualifizieren holen sie sich die leute
von goldman sachs und mixed mckinsey ins
haus die teures geld kosten und wohl
kaum das gemeinwohl im sinn haben
wohin die krise der demokratie und die
zerstörung des sozialen zusammenhalts
führen
das können sie hier auf der rechten
seite des parlaments besichtigen da
sitzt das ergebnis ihrer politik und es
ist nicht ungefährlich wenn sie sich
immer mit großer emotionaler geste über
die afg aufregen und gleichzeitig die
politik genau die politik fortsetzen die
diese partei erst stark gemacht hat
schon in den neunziger jahren haben zwei
sehr unterschiedliche männer vor den
konsequenzen gewarnt wenn große teile
der bevölkerung sich nicht mehr
politisch repräsentiert führen der
liberale dahrendorf hat 1997 darauf
hingewiesen dass die globalisierung
zitat die institutionen der demokratie
durch die konsequenz lose kommunikation
zwischen den individuen ersetzt und
deshalb ein jahrhundert des
autoritarismus befürchtet und der
schriftsteller stefan heym der als
jüdischer emigrant in der us armee gegen
die nazis gekämpft hat der hat schon
1992 gewarnt ich zitiere ich bin gleich
am ende wenn die leute sich nicht
artikulieren können denn werden sie
häuser anzünden und wenn man ihnen nicht
eine demokratische lösung anbieten kann
einen
so eine linke lösung dann werden sie
nach rechts gehen dann werden sie wieder
den faschismus folgen und deshalb ist
ihr weiter so nicht zu verantworten
unser land braucht dringend einen
sozialen und demokratischen neubeginn
noch ist es nicht so spät
[Applaus]